[Musique]
l'homme a toujours été fasciné par les
forces extrêmes de la nature certains en
font même un métier comme les chasseurs
de tornades mais aussi passionnant qu'il
puisse paraître ce métier comporte son
lot de risque et des puissances de la
nature peuvent se retourner à tout
moment contre l'homme
le métier de volcanologue est également
très exposé il est rempli de revirements
incontrôlable un seul faux pas et
l'ascension d'un volcan pourrait être la
dernière
Greg Johnson est l'un des meilleurs
chasseurs de tornades professionnels en
Amérique du Nord avec plus de 10 ans
d'expérience ses collègues et lui
nommaient les Tornado Hunter ont
sillonné l'Amérique sur plus de 200000
km à bord de leur camion blindé pour
filmer photographier étudié et diffuser
des informations sur les tornades
Nick Varlet et volcanologue et
professeur chercheur fondateurs du
département volcanique à l'université de
Colima au Mexique
il a exploré des dizaines de volcans à
travers le monde pour améliorer la
recherche il concentre aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de son exploration et de sa
quête de données sur le volcan de Colima
qui fait partie des volcans les plus
dangereux au monde
Greg Johnson et Nick Varlet sont deux
fervents travailleurs conscients qu'à
tout moment un faux pas pourrait avoir
raison de leur passion
[Musique]
le métier de chasseur de tornades
comporte une grande part de risques la
moindre faute d'appréciation peut mener
tout droit à la catastrophe
[Musique]
les risques d'accidents sont très
fréquents dans le métier de chasseur de
tornade à tout moment un demi-tour
soudain de cette force de la nature peut
s'avérer fatal
chaque année aux États-Unis les tornades
font en moyenne 70 victimes et 1500
blessés
la saison des tornades est à son summum
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Greg et ses équipiers se
préparent à partir à la poursuite des
tornades dans le centre des États-Unis
je suis Greg Johnson photographe et mon
rôle est plutôt simple je dois faire les
photos les plus incroyables possibles
de la planification c'est-à-dire savoir
où nous allons et comment nous y allons
il y a aussi
de la diffusion en direct sur Internet
et de nos vidéos en ligne
qui est le conducteur il apprend l'art
de la photographie au fil de nos
déplacements voilà c'est notre équipe
nous sommes trois
en ce moment c'est la mi-saison de la
chasse au tornade ce n'est pas une
période très longue 12 semaines tout au
plus certaines années c'est plutôt neuf
ou dix semaines ah oui
cette fameuse tornade vous savez cette
tornade légendaire des prairies à
laquelle on pense quand on regarde des
films ou des émissions à la télé
parfaite immense touchant le sol et qui
donne de superbes photos
il n'en a pas eu cette année
on a beaucoup de photos mais je ne fais
pas ce métier et je ne parcours pas des
milliers de kilomètres en camion pour
prendre de jolies photos je veux faire
des photos de tornade
père de quatre enfants greg est bien
conscient des nombreux risques associés
à son activité
c'est comme ça que je gagne ma vie au
début c'était difficile de partir ça ne
me dérange pas quand je suis sur la
route le moment difficile c'est de
monter dans la voiture et de partir je
ne crois pas que les enfants ont peur
mais je pense que ce qui les affecte
c'est quand les gens font des
commentaires ils disent votre père est
fou votre père
et
ne disent pas ça
bon d'accord peut-être que j'ai menti
à chaque fois que je pars sur la route
[Musique]
pour Greg la sécurité prime avant tout
et sa grande expérience en la matière
lui permet de bien prévoir tout
l'équipement indispensable à
l'expédition
c'est pourquoi lui et son équipe se
déplace dans un véhicule blindé
hautement modifié il se protège ainsi de
la plupart des risques de collision avec
des débrumes
[Musique]
et ce soir ce camion c'est flash on peut
compter sur lui c'est comme un cocon qui
nous protège alors tout ce qui se passe
dans le camion doit être sécurisé qu'il
s'agisse de conduire en direction d'une
tornade ou de rester assis à l'intérieur
pendant une tempête de grêle on doit
être en sécurité
oh non
oh non c'est pas vrai
ils doivent être sous sol
c'est terrible
pour qu'on soit en sécurité
ce camion a été renforcé afin qu'il
puisse résister à tous les imprévus
le véhicule étendu de Line ex une
matière par balle
lors d'une tornade le vin peut atteindre
jusqu'à 400 km/h
il s'agisse d'une roche d'un morceau de
bois ou d'un pain de maison lorsqu'ils
sont dans les airs ça peut faire
beaucoup de dommages on a aussi cette
cage de sécurité
elle est conçue pour être placée dans la
charpente du camion
si le véhicule est renversé
elle protège l'habitacle du camion là où
on est assis et où on passe tout notre
temps elle nous empêche d'être écraser
malgré toutes ces précautions le camion
porte les marques de ses expéditions
antérieures son pare-brise a été
fracassé à huit reprises
[Musique]
tout comme Greg Chris chic son
partenaire a choisi d'exercer ce métier
il est conscient des risques qu'il prend
en tant que chasseur de tornades et de
l'inquiétude que ressent Chelsea sa
femme lorsqu'il part en expédition
[Musique]
de faire ce que j'aime
si
elle pleure à chaque fois que je pars
pas le problème c'est pas la chasse aux
tornades je crois que c'est plutôt
l'aspect sécurité le danger la conduite
les longues heures passées sur la route
et tout ça c'est ce qui lui fait peur
quand Chris n'est pas là c'est très
difficile pour moi
je m'inquiète beaucoup pour lui
je passe beaucoup de temps à essayer de
savoir où il se trouve quand il n'est
pas là
j'essaie de suivre les diffusions en
direct pour m'assurer qu'ils vont bien
je crois que c'est un métier très
dangereux
je ne comprends pas pourquoi il veut
faire ça
ce n'est pas ce que je souhaiterais
qu'il fasse j'aimerais qu'il y ait un
travail régulier de 9 à 5 comme les
autres maris
Greg Chris et Ricky vont parcourir
environ 2000 km pour se rendre à leur
premier point de destination au Texas
mais ce trajet peut changer à tout
moment une nouvelle alerte météo et une
analyse poussée des données du radar
satellite mène regret a changé de cap au
beau milieu d'une chasse
[Musique]
le métier de volcanologue est également
une profession très Ariste sur le
terrain les dangers de blessures
sérieuses ou même de mort sont
omniprésents
à l'aide de divers instruments le
volcanologue doit observer étudier et
effectuer des prélèvements et cela sur
des volcans en pleine activité
Nick Varlet enseignant d'origine
anglaise concentre depuis quelques
années ses recherches sur le volcan de
Colima l'un des plus dangereux au monde
ce matin unique se prépare à rejoindre
ses étudiants pour organiser une
expédition sur le volcan
mais avant de partir ce père de famille
attentionné passe un petit moment avec
son fils tu vois c'est à cause du gaz
celui-là provient d'une énorme éruption
du volcan Colima
mais tu sais que je reviens toujours
je sais ça tu préfères celle-ci je
préfère celle-là
la journée du volcanologue commence
maintenant Nick se dirige vers le lieu
de rencontre pour l'expédition à
l'université de Colima
le matériel scientifique est déjà
préparé nous devons charger le camion ce
qui j'espère ne prendra pas trop de
temps ensuite nous devons aller à
l'université la température est bonne
pour cette période de l'année parce
qu'elle peut rendre des choses
difficiles alors il faut profiter du
temps qu'il fait aujourd'hui
à lui-même fondé le département de
volcanologie de Colima et ses étudiants
viennent des quatre coins du monde
aujourd'hui le volcanologue est quelques
élèves graviront le volcan à la
recherche d'échantillons et de donner
très utile
elle serviront aux analyses pour les
prévisions d'activité volcaniques et
pourront ainsi aider à sauver des vies
lors d'évacuation de population vivant
près d'un volcan
le volcan est très intéressant en ce
moment il est en éruption depuis 2013 et
en constante évolution
quand les différents éléments sont
instables il peut devenir plus dangereux
et provoquer une plus grosse éruption
du coup c'est important en ce moment de
collecter autant de données que nous
pouvons
il est très difficile d'étudier des
volcans en éruption
parce que plusieurs d'entre eux sont
trop dangereux pour être approchés
et l'avantage que nous avons ici c'est
que ce volcan est en éruption mais qu'on
peut s'en approcher c'est une
opportunité très rare c'est difficile de
trouver ça ailleurs
pas de temps à perdre ni qui son équipe
prépare tout le matériel nécessaire pour
leur expédition sur le Colima à cette
période de l'année nous nous battons
constamment contre les éléments parce
qu'il peut pleuvoir énormément sur le
Colima pendant la saison des pluies
pendant 3 ou 4 jours et ça devient
impossible de faire quoi que ce soit sur
le terrain alors on attend toujours un
moment comme aujourd'hui qui nous offre
une opportunité idéale
Nick n’en est pas à sa première
ascension du volcan il connaît bien le
terrain mais devra constamment être sur
ses gardes pour ne pas mettre en danger
ses étudiants
alors par là à Ricky
quand la nature se déchaîne les
chasseurs de tornades vivent des moments
intenses mais devant ce phénomène d'une
puissance hors norme la curiosité reste
plus forte que la peur arrête ici arrête
il s'est arrêté
Greg et son équipe ne sont pas près
d'oublier cette journée d'été de 2014
dans la plaine de l'état du Nebraska ils
sont tombés sur une super tornade qui
rase tout sur son passage
les sirènes d'alerte au tornade
retentissent en ce moment dans cette
petite ville de pinger en Nebraska on a
cette tornade géante au sol juste ici
c'est exactement ce qu'on recherchait
cette saison c'est notre récompense
ouais
c'est vraiment incroyable
regarde la taille de ce truc il se
dirige tout droit vers cette ville
regarde regarde à gauche il y en a une
deuxième juste là
pour observer et relever des
informations il faut se rapprocher au
plus près des tornades il faut oublier
sa peur mais restez toujours concentré
sur le danger omniprésent
allons-y allez allez on y va là tout se
joue entre risque et raison devant
appareil spectacle
tu as entendu ça
elles sont derrière ce monticule elles
sont derrière ce monticule
derrière la colline
les tornades évoluent sur une dizaine de
kilomètres en moyenne et sont large
d'une centaine de mètres à l'intérieur
les vents sont les plus violents de la
planète ils peuvent atteindre jusqu'à
500 km heure et dévasté tout sur leur
passage c'est pas bon
c'est pas mon
comme ça mais c'est faux elle ne tourne
pas comme ça elle partent en
tire-bouchon
donc la force verticale à l'intérieur
d'une tornade est aussi puissante que la
force horizontale
mais aussi de s'envoler dans les airs
le danger c'est le vent qui entraîne
tout vers l'intérieur mais on se
débrouille avec ça
une fois que tu te retrouves coincé dans
la circulation d'air tu risques de
t'envoler dans les airs et c'est cet
aspect qui était effrayant et dangereux
quand on se trouve près d'une tornade on
est soumis à un changement extrême de la
pression barométrique une tornade c'est
un système de basse pression plus on
s'approche de la tornade plus la
pression baisse c'est ce phénomène que
les gens qui se sont retrouvés au cœur
d'une tornade en vécue cette impression
que leurs oreilles vont exploser
c'est ma passion parfois j'ouvre une
photo sur mon ordinateur et je ne peux
pas croire que c'est moi qui l'ai prise
je m'assois et je la regarde
certaines photographies sortent du lot
il y en a que j'ai prise l'an dernier à
vigueur une petite ville de Nebraska
dans notre cercle de météorologue on va
parler de cette journée pour les 50
prochaines années
on a observé des tornades jumelles l'une
à côté de l'autre
chacune d'entre elles avaient une
largeur de près d'un kilomètre et elle
parcourait le sol en même temps côte à
côte
j'ai été témoin de ça juste devant moi
[Musique]
de tornades au sol tu veux rire
mon Dieu l'anticipation est primordiale
pour nos chasseurs de tornades car il
suffit d'un revirement soudain de
trajectoire mal interprété et c'est la
tragédie
mais elle se dirige par
tout va bien je te mettrai jamais en
danger
avant chaque départ Nick doit se rendre
à l'Observatoire de la protection civile
de Jalisco au pied du Colima il doit
rencontrer l'équipe de techniciens qui
surveille 24 heures sur 24 les activités
du volcan pour s'assurer de ne pas se
faire prendre dans une éruption
après avoir obtenu les autorisations
nécessaires le petit groupe se lance sur
la piste kaouteuse qui va les conduire
au pied du volcan mais rien ne garantit
cependant la sécurité de l'équipe dans
un environnement qui peut se transformer
en immense piège à tout moment
plusieurs dangers guettent les
volcanologues explosion chute de roche
pyroclastique cendres chaudes glissement
de terrain ou encore coulé de lave
[Musique]
à cette période de l'année Nick doit
faire face à un autre danger
principal danger ici à cette période de
l'année c'est la pluie parce qu'elle se
mêle au dépôt qui se trouve dans le haut
du volcan
les entraînent avec elle et forme
debout peuvent devenir très épaisses et
entraînés avec elles de gros débris
potentiellement dangereux
c'est une ancienne coulée
plateau où se trouve les instruments de
mesure et d'analyses les moindres
soubresaut et changement d'humeur de la
montagne sont enregistrés
sur une longue distance du coup on peut
la recueillir facilement en ce moment
c'est trop dangereux de s'approcher pour
collecter à la matière pyroclastique qui
s'écoule du volcan du coup c'est tout ce
qu'on peut recueillir ensuite on peut
l'analyser pour voir si la composition
du magma est restée la même ou si elle
est en train de changer
[Musique]
panneau solaire ordinateur enregistreur
sismique et caméra thermique du matériel
à la pointe de la technologie pour
surveiller le moindre mouvement du
volcan cette caméra est orientée vers le
volcanal régulier selon la programmation
et on peut sélectionner les images
d'éruption P4 d'exploitation
ici nous avons la station radar qui se
trouve dans une boîte étanche
c'est une pièce d'équipement plutôt
sophistiqué
du volcan
ensuite si l'émission perçoit un
mouvement elle le détecte et renvoie un
signal
après avoir récupéré les données
numériques l'expédition se poursuit sur
le Colima aujourd'hui l'activité
volcanique de la montagne est beaucoup
trop dangereuse pour la gravir jusqu'au
sommet malgré les risques le
volcanologue et ses étudiants se rendent
le plus près possible du cratère
menaçant règle numéro une toujours
garder une distance de sécurité avec le
cratère car lorsqu'un volcan devient
dangereux la seule véritable protection
reste la fuite
après avoir passé la nuit dans un hôtel
Greg et son équipe décide de changer
l'itinéraire les chasseurs de tornades
ne savent jamais à l'avance ou leur
quête les mènera
on a décidé à la dernière minute de
changer de direction
alors on se dirige vers le Colorado
maintenant qui se trouve à 6 heures de
route d'ici
on part pas maintenant
on risque de rater le spectacle il y a
rien de pire que de conduire pendant 6
heures pour rater quelque chose à 5 ou
10 minutes
c'est arrivé ça arrive et c'est un
sentiment terrible
nos chasseurs de tornades décident de
quitter le Texas et de mettre le cap sur
le Colorado ou des conditions propices
aux tornades se dessine ils vont devoir
effectuer un parcours d'un millier de
kilomètres pour rejoindre le phénomène
il n'y a aucune minute à perdre dans
cette course contre la montre
et Greg garde toujours un oeil ouvert
sur ses instruments de lecture pour être
là au bon moment un chasseur de tornades
doit avoir un qui plusieurs
connaissances scientifiques au cours de
sa carrière
nous donne des informations sur la
direction des vents
cet autre côté nous informe de
l'intensité de l'orage
alors on se contente de faire c'est de
trouver une tempête qui combine des
pluies intenses d'importantes chutes de
grêle et des vents rotatifs
ce sont ces vents rotatifs qui finiront
par provoquer une tempête susceptible de
produire une tornade
la moindre accalmie s'avère trompeuse
sur la route des tornades le danger
survient quand on s'y attend le moins
le fait d'avoir un orage est plutôt
génial
ce qui arrive avec ce genre de tempête
c'est qu'elle produisent des éclairs
incroyables
était tout près regardez ça en tête
les éclairs beaucoup plus que les
tornades on peut voir la tornade arriver
à plus d'une quinzaine de kilomètres de
distance
on peut la voir on sait où elle sera à
ça
il y en avait un là et un autre là-bas
c'est pas une bonne situation pour nous
en ce moment
faut l'entendre maintenant
on peut entendre la graine et la pluie
tomber sur le gazon et les buissons
là-bas
on peut l'entendre rapprocher
avant de partir
c'est le moment de partir
le camion protège ses occupants des
risques de collision mais il protège
aussi de la foudre lorsqu'ils sont à
découvert elle peut s'abattre sur Greg
ou ses amis
dans le métier les chasseurs de tornades
doivent souvent changer leur plan ils
sont tributaires des changements
soudains de météo
la chance est un facteur important de la
chasse aux tempêtes
la science les chiffres et les
mathématiques en sont également des
éléments majeurs
il y a une raison qui fait qu'on peut
conduire sur une distance de 3000 km en
deux jours
précis où une tornade d'apparentiel on
n'arrive pas là par hasard
dans une minute j'espère qu'on pourra
avoir une tornade traverser la route
devant nous
ce qui se produit dans les nuages
maintenant dépend de la chance
je dirais que
nous sommes certains à 100% d'atteindre
la tempête
là où la chance intervient
c'est que seulement une tempête sur 20
risque de produire une tornade
est-ce que je l'ai eu
elle devrait être ici elle devrait être
juste là où elle est
dans les deux prochaines minutes ces
routes deviendront très glissantes très
dangereuses et vous ne voulez pas rester
coincé dans un fossé lorsqu'on tempête
se dirige vers vous
faudra penser à partir on peut voir
l'air qui est aspiré là-bas tout est
aspiré on voit du vert du bleu ça
signifie qu'il y a de la graine
là-dedans en ce moment
il commence à pleuvoir
je suis d'accord avec toi ah oui je
crois tu crois que
Greg devra encore une fois chercher une
nouvelle formation de tornade
[Musique]
depuis le début du XVIIIe siècle les
phénomènes volcaniques ont fait plus de
200 000 victimes un bon volcanologue
doit toujours faire preuve d'extrême
prudence les volcans sont sournois et
peuvent rapidement devenir très menaçant
quelques accidents fatals se sont
malheureusement produits
[Musique]
un couple de volcanologue Maurice et
Katia kraft aperrit le 3 juin 91 sur les
flancs du volcan inzen au Japon ils
étaient reconnus pour être
particulièrement téméraires lors de
leurs expéditions pendant l'ascension du
monde zen les crafts se sont approchés
trop près d'une zone très risquée
à l'époque un professeur chargé de la
surveillance du volcan leur avait
déconseillé la zone mais ils n'en n'ont
pas tenu compte et cette fois-ci leur
fougue a eu raison 2 ce n'était pas pour
rien qu'on les surnommé les volcanovs
[Musique]
Jacques Marie bardef écrivain et
volcanologue aguerri a visité la plupart
des volcans actifs au cours de sa
carrière
[Musique]
Jacques Marie connaissait bien le couple
kraft
c'était pour moi un grand frère et une
grande sœur
faut savoir que Maurice et Katia étaient
de formidable cinéastes et photographe
en fait c'était volcanologues mais par
le biais de leur conférence de leur
livre c'est il vivait de ça
[Musique]
ils apprennent le début juin 1991 que le
monde zen entre en éruption brusquement
donc ils y vont et c'était le début de
l'éruption c'est pour ça que c'était
assez trompeur parce qu'en début
d'éruption on sait jamais François va
faire un volcan donc il avait fait ou il
est en train de faire des nuages et bien
sûr Maurice et Katia voulait faire des
images pédagogiques et scientifiques et
d'intérêt général c'était le début de
l'éruption et volcans étaient en pleine
surpression et en fait la nuit ardente
qui est parti donc ce nuage brûlant à
grande vitesse et ben il a été deux fois
plus important que prévu il a été deux
fois plus large
donc en fait dans son passé à côté des
grattes malheureusement il est passé sur
eux
donc ils ont été bien sûr tués sur le
coup asphyxier brûler emporter
[Musique]
mais également bien plus bas sur la
route il y avait toute la presse
japonaise et donc 39 journalistes des
médias qui était là à un endroit va dire
qui était conseil comme à peu près sûr
parce que c'était sur la route ils ont
également été tués
protéger des nuits ardentes comme dans
le cas des craft aucun aucune protection
n'est possible parce qu'en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que également il y a
Netflix il y a des gaz chauds brûlants
donc même si on a une protection les gaz
vont rentrer par en dessous par les
jointures il y a des brûlures il y a de
l'asphyxie donc on peut pas on va dire
on pourrait peut-être
résister on va dire peut-être 30
secondes voire une minute mais bon la
nuit ardente plusieurs minutes on couvre
tout les deux gaz brûlants de cendres
c'est vrai que la meilleure défense d'un
mot canox c'est la fuite
ça a été une énorme émotion en France
parce que les kraft étaient extrêmement
populaires on les aimait bien ils
étaient chaleureux marrants
[Musique]
pour moi ça a été une
leçon douloureuse mais je me suis dit
bon ben je pense que depuis ce jour-là
j'ai été encore plus prudent en disant
je suis pas à l'abri de d'un mauvais
coup mais je fais encore plus attention
en pensant justement à Maurice et Katia
l'approche à la fois scientifique et
éducative des kraft séduisez autant les
adeptes de la volcanologie que le grand
public
ils ont grandement aidé à faire évoluer
cette mystérieuse science mais cela leur
a été fatal
[Musique]
elle Réno Oklahoma en 2013 cette région
du centre des États-Unis allait subir
les effets dévastateurs de la plus large
tornade jamais observée dans ce pays les
gars vous devez voir ce qui se passe sur
le radar nos chasseurs étaient au
première loge dans le feu de l'action et
sous l'effet de l'adrénaline ils ont mal
évalué le danger qu'il courait
regardez la rotation au dessus de nous
les gars
[Musique]
sans le savoir le piège est en train de
se refermer sur eux
cette journée aurait pu être leur
dernière Greg et ses deux partenaires se
sont approchés beaucoup trop près de la
formation
[Musique]
allez allez allez bien bien allons-y
la seule fois où on a pris des décisions
qui auraient pu nous mettre en danger
c'est à elle Reno
l'erreur qu'on a fait l'erreur que tout
le monde a fait c'est d'attendre trop
longtemps avant de partir alors que la
tornade se déplaçait droit vers nous
elle vient vers nous les gars attendez 2
secondes de plus bougez pas
un certain point
et qu'on était prêt à partir lors des 30
secondes qui ont suivi parce que ça n'a
pas pris plus de 30 secondes l'ampleur
de la tornade est passée de quelques
mètres de large à 2,6 miles de large
soit environ 4 km
ok partons partons maintenant s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
on était tous beaucoup trop près on a
attendu trop longtemps avant de partir
[Musique]
les oreilles sont bouchées les gars
allez allez
un gros éclair devant nous un gros
éclair on est dans le tourbillon en ce
moment on est dans le tourbillon à
l'instar de Greg et de son équipe
d'autres chasseurs de tornades venus
observer le phénomène se sont trouvés
également piégés c'est pas vrai des
débris délivré à la poche cette chose
immense se rapproche c'est pas vrai
au milieu des débris qui volent dans
tous les sens ils essaient de sortir de
l'enfer
[Musique]
tu vas bien
pourquoi est-ce que cet homme s'arrête
les chasseurs de tornades se lancent
dans une course folle dans l'espoir
d'échapper au chaos
attention à cette voiture attention à
cette voiture
les caméras captent des images
saisissantes de ces instants où tout
peut basculer
[Musique]
allez
allez allez
j'essaie
[Musique]
allez allez
vraiment beau travail on est sorti on
est sorti
leur camion blindé a été fortement
endommagé heureusement pour eux ils
n'ont pas été blessés dans cette
mésaventure qui aurait pu les mener tout
droit au drame
mais certains ont eu moins de chance que
les autres
qui a traversé le Cloud vendredi à tuer
13 personnes selon le nouveau bilan
révisé à la hausse par les autorités cet
autre personne dans 5 enfants sont
toujours portées disparus parmi les
victimes trois chasseurs de tempête dont
team Samara l'un des plus connus dans le
monde
était un gars très positif et brillant
un des meilleurs chasseurs de tempêtes
que j'ai rencontré
vu l'état dans lequel on a trouvé le
véhicule des Samara c'est de quareg il
était impossible qu'il s'en sorte vivant
nous chassions la tornade d'alredo et
nous étions tous les deux sur une route
de terre comme celle-ci en descendant
il était environ 1,6 km derrière nous
nous étions devant la tornade d'arrivée
comme ça il allait devenue immense en 30
secondes à peine
nous étions extérieurs
nous avions à toute vitesse la tornade
nous retenait un peu mais nous nous en
sommes sortis mais il n'a pas pu sortir
parce qu'il roulait sur une route de
terre il pouvait pas passer par le champ
car ils conduisait une voiture de
location alors il est resté prisonnier
il pouvait pas sortir la voiture s'est
retrouvée projetée dans la tornade a
probablement été soulevé et projeté à
nouveau
c'était très triste
cette tornade détient le record de
largeur jamais enregistré à ce jour avec
une étendue de 4 km de
force 5 sur l'échelle de Fujita s'évant
dévastateur ont atteint 475 km heure
la tempête del Reynaud était une
monstrueuse
ce n'est jamais arrivé dans toute
l'histoire
de chasse au tornade
il n'aurait pas essayé sa zone de sûreté
était probablement à environ un
kilomètre et demi d'une tornade mais ce
jour-là quelque chose a mal tourné et il
a pas survécu
non
la force colossale est dévastatrice de
la tornade d'alredo à malheureusement
porté avec elle la vie de ses passionnés
de phénomènes extrêmes
[Musique]
et nique et ses étudiants sont
maintenant arrivés dans l'une des
crevasses du volcan
ouais bien nous sommes maintenant au
fond de cette section du ravin le ravin
de San Antonio
c'est un peu dangereux ici il faut être
prudent parce que ces parois sont très
instables et les pierres peuvent tomber
facilement
niquent n'en est pas à sa première
visite sur le Colima mais malgré sa
grande expérience il sait que chaque
ascension comporte son lot de risque
très très vite on peut se retrouver avec
des chutes de boue et des lards qui
coulent par ici il se forme très
rapidement quand il pleut et peuvent se
transformer en piège mortel comme vous
pouvez le voir il y a peu d'endroits
pour s'échapper
du coup il y a peu d'issue une île à
côté ni de l'autre il faut être très
prudent
le groupe ne peut pas s'attarder sur ce
terrain trop hasardeux chaque minute est
compté il doit se rendre à un point
d'observation au milieu du volcan pour
ériger le campement et ce avant la
tombée du jour si la lave des volcans
n'est pas le plus grand des dangers pour
les volcanologues elle peut occasionner
de graves séquelles nique le sait bien
il en a payé le prix lors d'une
expédition sur un autre volcan
en plus de celui de Colima je travaille
sur deux ou trois autres volcans l'un
d'entre eux s'appellent l'Islas Sokoro
j'y étais il y a quelques années pour
mesurer le champ magnétique je
transportais sur mon dos un appareil
avec une antenne
[Musique]
qui est un peu chaude je me suis dit je
vais plutôt marcher sur ce terrain plat
là-bas il y a pas debout
mauvaise idée
j'ai fait un pas et malheureusement le
sol était recouvert d'une couche
d'environ 1 cm d'épaisseur qui cachait
une boue brûlante en dessous
debout brûlante plutôt épaisse
mais assez liquide pour recouvrir et
s'infiltrer dans ma box
je ne pouvais rien faire
malheureusement j'ai tenté d'y mettre
l'autre pied pour récupérer celui qui
était dans la boue
j'avais du mal parce que j'étais dans
une pente
à ce moment là j'ai pas réalisé la
gravité de ce qui se passait cette boue
était à 92 degrés et entrez dans mes
deux bottes je me suis assis j'ai enlevé
mes bottes puis mes chaussettes au début
j'avais pas mal mais peu de temps après
j'ai ressenti une intense douleur
puisque mes pieds étaient gravement
brûlés
les brûlures que je me suis faite à ce
moment là sur une partie de mon pied
était des brûlures au troisième degré
pour chaque excursion le volcanologue
doit optimiser sa présence et recueillir
le maximum de données
leur campement installé Nick profite de
la soirée pour capter des images
infrarouges à l'aide de sa caméra
on peut lire une température d'environ
47 degrés en ce moment au sommet
de la distance les pixels sont plutôt
gros
ça veut dire que la température sera
beaucoup plus élevée que ça je peux voir
plusieurs points chauds en fait vous
pouvez voir qu'une coulée pyroclastique
est passée par ici probablement dans les
derniers jours elle a laissé une belle
entrain de chaude jusqu'en bas du volcan
pendant toute la nuit l'équipe devra se
relayer pour surveiller les moindres
changements du volcan en activité à tout
moment elle pourra ainsi lancer un appel
de détresse et rapidement évacuer le
site
[Musique]
sur les routes du Kansas les chasseurs
de tornade pour suivre leur trace
en ce moment on se dirige vers des
orages qui se sont formés au train de
SAS
on doit pratiquement traverser les temps
en voiture
il y a des risques de tornade
aujourd'hui mais en ce moment on ne voit
rien qui puisse présager d'une tornade
au sol
nous avons tué doivent maintenant se
rendre le plus près possible de la
perturbation atmosphérique
[Musique]
lors de grosses tempêtes soudaine les
routes deviennent particulièrement
dangereuses pour les automobilistes
tu as été poussé hors de la route non je
suis simplement arrivé trop vite je ne
voyais pas ce qui était sur la route
les cours d'eau longeant les routes
débordent rapidement et rendent la
conduite très compliquée
c'est bon c'est bon
dérapages et embardés tout peut arriver
Greg et son équipe ont souvent à
intervenir pour aider les gens en
détresse je te dirai quand ce sera le
bon moment
dirige-toi vers la droite
[Applaudissements]
cet homme conduisait sur cette route et
regardez ça l'eau c'est cool de sa
voiture en ce moment il a roulé dans
l'eau
ce sont des inondations éclairs qui
peuvent être aussi dangereuses que la
tornade sinon plus
comme vous pouvez le voir il conduisait
sur cette route à une vitesse normale et
soudainement toute cette rivière se
ruisseau a inondé la route il a roulé
dans l'eau son véhicule a fait de
l'aquaplaning
et il s'est retrouvé dans le fossé
n'est pas très profond mais vous pouvez
imaginer ce qui aurait pu arriver s'il
s'agissait d'un ravin ou si la rivière
était plus grosse peut-être qu'il serait
sous l'eau vous savez alors c'est
effrayant mais heureusement je crois
qu'il va bien s'en tirer
d'accord les gars passez une bonne
journée
oh non
[Musique]
après une longue journée de chasse au
tornades les temps d'ado Hunter sont en
route à leur hôtel leur journée n'a pas
été des plus fructueuse mais soudain la
chance leur sourit
tout un spectacle de lumière c'est
génial combien de fois ça nous est
arrivé de nous dire on a fini pour la
nuit fermant tout ça et puis boum on
voit apparaître une alerte de tornade
dans le noir
une nouvelle alerte météo se déclenche
les enfants d'une possible formation de
Tornade et ce tout près de leur position
la rotation est ici on est là on se
trouve directement au nord mais elle
bouge traquer une tornade de nuit peut
Saver très risqué et Greg le sait bien
il fait noir on voit seulement quand il
y a un éclair
on se retrouve sous la grêle et de
fortes pluies en ce moment
ce n'est pas très sécurisé
Ricky est inquiet parce qu'on ne veut
pas se retrouver au milieu d'une tornade
la nuit alors ce qu'on va faire c'est
surveiller le radar et avec un peu de
chance dans quelques minutes elle va
passer juste devant nous
la pluie va cesser et on pourra avoir
une bonne visibilité s'il y a une
tornade au sol avec ces conditions on
pourrait avoir une chance de l'avoir
mais Greg doit parfois prendre quelques
risques il est toujours à la chasse aux
meilleures images de tornades c'est sa
passion et son métier
[Musique]
tellement près
merde oh
un tube entier c'est un tube entier qui
s'étend jusqu'au sol
magnifique
les chasseurs craquent sans aucune
visibilité il pourrait à tout moment se
retrouver à l'intérieur même de la
tornade et bien plus d'électricité
toute l'électricité
[Musique]
on n'était pas assez prêt pour
apercevoir des débris mais c'était un
bel entonnoir qui s'étendait jusqu'au
sol
il y a plus d'électricité à planes non
plus
il y a de très très forts qui
nourrissent cette tempête non
l'entonnoir est plutôt étroit au cœur de
l'action grec contact les services
d'urgence pour les aviser en temps réel
des développements du phénomène
ça va
je pense pas à mon ami
[Musique]
c'est où le problème ne bouge pas
ne bouge pas
[Musique]
elle vient de passer elle vient de
passer
la tornade est passée près de nous ça
s'est éclaircie juste devant nous
l'électricité est revenue à Plaine ça
veut dire que oh mon dieu oh mon dieu
et on est juste à l'ouest de planes en
ce moment on croit que la tornade ou des
vents très forts
la tornade bloquée la lumière il y a pas
eu de panne de courant la tornade se
trouvait entre nous et planes
regarde dans cette direction
est-ce que c'est ce que je pense là non
merci beaucoup
oh mon dieu va te faire voir c'était
trop près là ici elle est là elle est là
les dangers sont nombreux et guettent
toujours les chasseurs de tornades
sur le terrain chaque décision est
importante car un simple faux pas et
l'expédition pourrait s'avérer être la
dernière
le Colima reste imprévisible le volcan
est actif et les signes des mouvements
qui s'exerce en profondeur sont
observables sur les flancs
au cours des dernières heures une coulée
est apparue
nous nous trouvons maintenant à environ
2 km du volcan
ah comme vous pouvez le voir il y a des
chutes de pierre qui surviennent
constamment
alors je dois être très prudent
je dois être prêt à courir au cas où une
pierre viendrait à tomber
c'est important de récolter un bon
échantillon de cette coulée pour
l'analyser et voir s'il y a eu des
changements dans la composition du magma
on peut voir la différence dans ces
pierres juste là regardez celle-ci
[Musique]
ni décide de retourner là où il a
disposé ses instruments de mesure et
d'échantillonnage mais il craint le pire
son matériel a cessé de transmettre ses
données au moment même de la dernière
coulée
[Musique]
on peut voir la station radar juste
après le passage de la nuée ardente
comme vous pouvez le constater la
station
l'instrument en fait était juste ici à
l'intérieur d'une boîte de métal
alors ça va
voici l'antenne parabolique elle a été
tordu et elle s'est brisée
elle a été fracassée par de larges
pierres
vous pouvez voir que la peinture a été
brûlée
comme plusieurs des arbres alentours
d'ailleurs
chacune de ses expéditions mais son but
est justement de trouver les méthodes
les plus fiables de prédiction
d'éruption volcaniques il est consacre
toute son énergie c'est tout ce que je
peux transporter alors je retourne me
mettre en sécurité
le Colima surnommait volcan de feu peut
exploser à tout moment et causer
d'importants dégâts aux populations
avoisinantes shouda Guzman une ville
depuis de 97000 habitants est situé tout
près du volcan
il est difficile de sensibiliser ses
habitants au danger potentiel du Colima
plusieurs d'entre eux se sont habitués à
la présence de ce volcan qui partage
leur quotidien
c'est une réaction plutôt typique
la première réponse qu'on reçoit c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de crainte les gens
n'ont pas vraiment peur du volcan
mais quand on leur demande êtes-vous
certain que rien ne peut arriver ils
répondent et bien non je sais pas
vraiment alors je crois que de
nombreuses personnes essayent simplement
de ne pas y penser pour continuer à
vivre leur vie dans ces villages la
majorité des gens sont pauvres les
catastrophes naturelles ne sont pas
leurs préoccupations majeures c'est
plutôt de vivre au quotidien en n'ayant
pas assez d'argent
en réalité avoir un peu peur serait sans
doute une bonne chose
la situation est problématique quand il
y a une importante éruption et qu'il
faut évacuer les gens
les gens ne sont pas très heureux de
partir et il doute des motivations de
ceux qui leur donnent évacuation
la situation idéale je crois en ce qui
concerne n'importe quel volcan serait
que la population locale soit un peu
effrayée comme ça si les autorités
disent nous devons évacuer ils le font
le gouvernement doit toujours rester en
alerte pour évacuer rapidement la région
en cas de catastrophe
Nick désir survoler le Colima pour
prendre quelques clichés et observer les
activités du volcan sous un autre angle
[Musique]
il peut être très risqué de s'aventurer
en avion trop près du cratère en pleine
activité
la chaleur intense et les projections de
débris pourraient causer bien du tort à
l'appareil et à ses occupants ils
doivent être très prudents et ne pas
rester trop longtemps au dessus du
Colima
[Musique]
c'était un succès
nous avons réussi à avoir un nouveau
développement du dôme parce qu'il
s'étend maintenant vers le nord ce que
j'ignorais avant le vol
nous avons vu un rocher tombé ce qui est
une bonne façon de prouver que le dôme
s'étend qu'il est actif et qu'il atteint
maintenant le bord du cratère à présent
on devrait commencer à observer de plus
en plus de chutes de pierre chaque jour
du côté nord
l'expédition terminée Nick peut
maintenant rassembler toutes les
informations recueillies sur le terrain
elle lui permettront de réaliser plus
précisément le modèle thermodynamique du
volcan
ce modèle permettra d'anticiper et de
mieux prévoir les activités volcaniques
du Colima
les métiers de chasseurs de tornades et
de volcanologues sont des professions
qui ne peuvent s'exercer sans passion
grâce à elle Greg Nick surpasse leur
appréhension face aux puissantes forces
de la nature
s'ils acceptent de prendre autant de
risques pour eux-mêmes c'est qu'ils
savent que leurs informations seront
capitales pour protéger les populations
en danger
[Musique]